We're going to begin the class proper introduction to psychology with a
discussion about the brain.
And in particular I want to lead off the class,
um,
with an idea that the Nobel prize winning biologist Francis Crick described as
the astonishing hypothesis.
And the astonishing hypothesis is summarize like this as he writes.
The stop judging hypothesis is that you,
your joys and your sorrows,
your memories and your ambitions,
your sense of personal identity and free will are in fact no more than the
behavior of avast assembly of nerve cells and their associated molecules as
Lewis Carroll's Alice might have phrased it,
you're nothing but a pack of neurons.
Um,
it is fair to describe this as astonishing.
It is an odd and unnatural view and I don't actually expect people to believe it
at first.
It's an open question whether you believe it when this class comes to an end.
But I'd be surprised if many of you believe it.
Now,
most people don't.
Most people,
um,
in fact hold a different view.
Most people are dualists.
Now dualism is a very different doctrine,
is a doctrine that can be found in every religion.
And in most philosophical systems,
uh,
throughout history,
it was very explicit in Plato for instance.
But the most articulate and well known defender of dualism is the philosopher
Rene Descartes.
And Rene Descartes
explicitly asked a question,
are humans merely physical machines merely physical things?
And he answered no,
he agreed that animals are machines.
In fact,
he called them beast machines and said animals.
Nonhuman animals are merely robots.
But people are different.
There's a duality of people like animals.
We possess physical material bodies.
But unlike animals,
what we are is not physical.
We are immaterial souls that possess physical body,
that,
that have physical bodies that recite and physical bodies that connect to
physical bodies.
Um,
so this is known as dualism because the claim is for humans at least are two
separate things.
There's our material bodies and there's are immaterial minds.
Now they card may two arguments for dualism.
One argument,
um,
involved observations about human action.
So they lived in a fairly sophisticated time and his time did have robots.
These were not electrical robots.
Of course,
they were robots powered by hydraulics.
So they current would walk around the French Royal Gardens and a French royal
gardens were set up like a 17th century Disneyland.
They had these characters that would operate according to water flow.
And so if you stepped on a certain panel,
a swordsman would jump out with a sword.
If you step somewhere else,
a bathing beauty would cover herself up behind some bushes.
And they could have said,
boy,
these machines respond in certain ways to certain actions.
So machines can do certain things.
In fact,
he says our bodies worked out way too.
If you tap somebody on the knee,
your leg will jump out.
Well,
maybe that's all we are.
But they can't said that can't be.
Because there are things that humans do that no machine could ever do.
Humans are not limited to reflexive action.
Rather,
humans are capable of coordinated creative,
spunk and spontaneous things.
We can use language,
for instance,
and sometimes my use of language,
it can be reflexive.
Somebody says,
how are you?
And I said,
I am fine,
how are you?
But sometimes,
um,
I could say what I choose to be.
How are you?
Pretty damn good.
I can just choose.
And machines Descartes argued are incapable of that sort of choice.
Hence we are not mirror machines.
The second argument is of course quite famous and this was the method this he
came to using the method of doubt.
So he started asking himself the question,
what can I be sure of?
And he said,
well,
I believe there's a god,
but honestly I can't be sure there's a god.
I believe I live in a rich country,
but maybe I've been fooled.
Even said I,
I believe I have had friends and family,
but maybe I am being tricked.
Maybe an evil demon for instance,
has tricked me,
has diluted me into thinking I have experiences that aren't real.
And of course,
the modern version of this is the matrix.
The idea of the matrix is explicitly built upon Cartesian Descartes' worries
about an evil demon.
Maybe everything you're now experiencing is not real,
but rather as a product of some other,
perhaps my level and creature
Descartes similarly could,
could doubt he has bought,
he has a body.
In fact,
he noticed that mad men sometimes believe they have extra limbs or they believe
there are different sizes and shapes than they really are.
And the cars,
how do I know I'm not crazy?
I mean crazy.
People don't think they're crazy.
So the fact I don't think I'm crazy doesn't mean I'm not crazy.
How do I know?
Descartes said,
I'm not dreaming right now,
but there is one thing they'd car concluded that he can not doubt and answers.
He cannot doubt that he is himself thinking that would be self refuting.
And so they cart use the method of doubt to say there's something really
different about having a body that's always uncertain from having a mind.
And he used this argument as a way to support dualism as a,
as a a way to support the idea that bodies and minds are separate.
And so he concluded,
I knew that I was a substance,
a whole essence or nature of which is to think and that for its existence there
is no need of any place,
nor does it depend on any material thing.
That is to say the soul by which I am what I am is entirely distinct from body.
Now,
I said before that this is common sense and I want to illustrate the common
sense nature of this in a few ways.
One thing is our dualism as a mashing or language.
So we have a certain mode of talking about things that we own or things that are
close to us,
my arm,
my heart,
my child,
my car.
But we also extend that to my body and my brain.
We talk about owning our brains as if we're somehow separate from them.
Are Dualism shows up in intuitions about personal identity.
And what this means is that common sense tells us that somebody can be the same
person even if their body undergoes radical and profound changes.
Um,
the best examples of this are fictional.
So we have no wonder,
no problem understanding a movie where somebody goes to sleep as a teenager in,
wakes up as Jennifer Garner as an older person.
Now,
now nobody,
nobody says,
oh,
that's a documentary.
I believe that.
Thoroughly true.
But at the same time,
nobody,
no adult,
no teenager,
no child ever leaves,
says I'm totally conceptually confused.
Rather,
we follow,
we follow the story.
We can also follow stories,
um,
which involve more profound transformations as when a man dies and is reborn
into the body of a child.
Now you might have different views around people around this room will have
different views as to whether reincarnation really exists,
but we can imagine it.
We can imagine a person dying and then reemerging and another body.
This is not Hollywood invention,
that one of the great short stories of the last century begins with the sentence
by Franz Kafka.
As Gregor Samsa woke one morning from uneasy dreams,
he found himself transformed in his bed into a gigantic insect.
And again,
Kafka invites us to imagine waking up into a body of a cockroach and we can,
this is also not modern.
Hundreds of years before the birth of Christ,
homer described the fate of the companions of Odysseus who were transformed by a
witch into pigs.
Actually,
that's not quite right.
She didn't turn them in at the pigs.
She did something worse.
She stuck them in the bodies of pigs.
They had the head and voice and bristles and body of swine,
but their minds remained unchanged as before,
so they were pen there weeping and we are invited to imagine the fate of again
finding ourselves in the bodies of other creatures.
And if you could imagine this,
this is because you are imagining what you are as separate from the body that
you reside residing.
We allow for the notion that many people can occupy one body.
This is a mainstay of some slapstick humor,
including the classic movie.
All of me,
Steve Martin,
Lily Tomlin,
highly recommended,
but many people think this sort of thing really happens.
One analysis,
a multiple personality disorder is that you have many people inside a single
body fighting it out for control.
Now we will discuss multiple personalities sort of towards the end of the
semester and it turns out things are a good deal.
More complicated than this,
but still my point isn't about how it really is,
but how we think about it.
Common Sense tells us you could have more than one person inside a single body.
This shows up in a different context involving exorcisms were many belief
systems allow for the idea that people's behavior,
particularly they're evil or irrational behavior could be because something else
has taken over their bodies.
Finally,
um,
most people around the world,
all religions and most people in most countries that most times believe that
people can survive the destruction of their bodies.
Um,
now cultures differ according to the fate of the body.
Some cultures have the body going to hit,
sorry,
the fate of the soul.
Some cultures have you going to heaven or descending the hell.
Others have you occupied another body.
Um,
still others have you occupying a morphous spirit world.
But what they share is the idea that what you are is separable from this
physical thing you carry around.
And the physical thing,
um,
that you carry around a can be destroyed while you live on.
Um,
these views are particularly common in the United States.
Uh,
in one survey done in Chicago a few years ago,
people were asked her religion and then were asked what would happen to them
when they died.
Most people in the sample.
We're Christian and about 96% of Christian said,
when I die,
I'm going to go to heaven.
Some of the sample was Jewish.
Now,
Judaism is actually a religion with a less than clear story about the afterlife.
Still,
most of the subjects who identify themselves as Jewish said when they die,
they will go to heaven.
Um,
some of the sample denied having any religion at all,
said they have no religion at all.
Still,
when these people were asked what would happen when they would die,
most of them answered,
I'm going to go to heaven.
So dualism is in Mash.
It lot rests on it.
But as Chris points out,
the scientific consensus now is that dualism is wrong.
There is no you separable,
are separate from your body in particular.
There is no use separable from your brain.
To put it the way cognitive scientists and psychologists and neuroscientists
like to put it,
the mind is what the brain does.
The brain,
the mind reflects the workings of the brain.
Just like computation reflects the working of a computer.
Now,
why would you hold such an outrageous view?
Why would you reject dualism in favor of this alternative?
Well,
a few reasons.
One reason is dualism has always had its problems.
For one thing,
it's a profoundly unscientific doctrine.
We want to know as curious people
how children learn language,
what we find attractive or unattractive.
What's the basis for mental illness?
And dualism simply says it's all nonphysical as part of the ether and hence
fails to explain it more specifically duelist like Descartes struggle to explain
how a physical body connects to an immaterial soul.
What's the conduit?
How good this connection be made after all day card knew full well that there is
such a connection,
you're your body obeys your commands.
Um,
if you bang your toe stub your toe,
you feel pain.
If you drink alcohol,
it affects your reasoning.
But he could only wave his hands as to how this physical thing in the world
could connect to an immaterial mind.
They car when he was alive was reasonable enough concluding that physical
objects cannot do certain things.
He was reasonable left and concluding.
For instance,
as he did that there's no way a merely physical object could ever play a game of
chess because,
and that's such a capacity is beyond the capacity of the physical world.
And hence you have to apply,
you have to extend the explanation to an immaterial soul.
But now we know we have what,
what scientists call an existence proof.
We know physical objects can do complicated and interesting things.
We know for instance,
machines can play chess.
We know machines can manipulate symbols.
We know machines have limited capacities to engage in mathematical and logical
reasoning to recognize things to do various of computations.
And this makes it at least possible that we are such machines.
So one,
you can no longer say,
look,
physical things just can't do that because we know physical things can do a lot.
And this opens up the possibility that,
that,
that humans are physical things in particular that humans,
our brains.
Finally,
there is strong evidence that the brain is involved in mental life.
Somebody who hold the hell a dualist view.
Um,
that said that what we do and what we decided and what we think and what we want
are all,
have nothing to do with the physical world would be embarrassed by the fact that
the brain seems to correspond in intricate and,
and the Lamber ways to our mental life.
Um,
now this has been known for a long time.
Philosophers and psychologists knew for a long time they're getting smacked in
the head.
Could Change your mental faculties,
that diseases like syphilis could make you the range that chemicals like
caffeine and alcohol can affect how you think.
But what's new is we can now in different ways see the direct effects of mental
life.
Somebody with a severe and profound loss of mental faculties.
The deficit will be shown correspondingly in her brain.
Um,
studying is using imaging techniques like cat scans,
pet and FMRI,
ri illustrate that different parts of the brain are active at during different
parts of mental life.
For instance.
Um,
the different he seeing words,
hearing words,
reading words and generating words can correspond to different aspects of what
part of your brain is active.
To some extent,
if we put you in an Fmri scanner and observe what you're doing in real time by
looking at the activity patterns in your brain,
we can tell whether you're thinking about music or thinking about sex.
To some extent,
we can tell whether you're solving a moral dilemma versus something else.
And this is no surprise if what we are as to workings of our,
of our physical brains,
but it is extremely difficult to explain,
um,
if one is a dualist.
Now,
so what you have is the scientific consensus is that all a mental life,
including consciousness and emotions and choice morality are the products of
brain activities.
So you would expect that when you rip open the skull and look at the brain,
you'd see something glorious.
You'd see like,
I dunno,
a big shiny thing with glass tubes and blinding lights and,
and sparks and wonderful colors.
And actually the brain is just disgusting.
Um,
it looks like like an old meatloaf.
It's,
um,
it's,
it's gray.
When you take it out of the head,
it's called gray matter.
But that's just because it's out of the hat.
Inside the head is bright red because it's pulsing with blood.
It doesn't even taste good.
Um,
has,
has anybody in here ever even brain,
I mean it's good with cream sauce but everything's good with cream sauce.
So,
so,
so the question is how can something like this give rise to us?
And I mean you have to have some sympathy for four day card.
There was another argument,
day card could have made us a lot less subtle than the ones he did make,
which is that thing responsible for freewill and love and consciousness.
Ridiculous.
What I want to do and what the goal of of neuroscience is is to make it less
ridiculous to try to explain how the brain works,
how the brain can give rise to thought.
And what I want to do today is take a first stab at this question.
Um,
but it's something we'll continue to discuss throughout the course as we talk
about different aspects of mental life.
What I want to do though now is provide a big picture.
So I want to do is start off small with the smallest interesting part of the
brain and then get bigger and bigger and bigger.
Talk about how the small part of the brain,
the neurons,
the basic building blocks of thought combined to other mental structures and
then the different sub parts of the brain and finally to the whole thing.
So
one of the discoveries of psychology is that the basic unit of the brain appears
to be the neuron to neuron is a specific sort of cell and the neuron has three
major parts.
As you could see illustrated here.
Neurons actually look quite different from one another,
but this is a typical one.
There are the dendrites,
these little tentacles here and the dendrites get signals from other neurons.
Now these signals can be either excitatory,
which is that they raised the likelihood to neuron will fire or inhibitory and
that they lower the likelihood that the neuron will fire.
The cell body sums it up and you could view it arithmetically.
The excitatory signals are pluses,
the inhibitory ones are minuses.
And then if you get a certain number of plus 60 or something,
the neuron will fire and it fires along the Axon.
The thing to the right,
the Axon is um,
much longer than the dendrites.
And in fact,
some axons are many feet long.
Um,
there's an axon leading from your spinal cord to your big toe.
For instance.
It is so shocking.
The lights out.
I'm surrounded surrounding to complete a mechanical metaphor that would've led
Descartes to despair.
Thank you,
Pauline.
Um,
so rounding the Axon is a Myelin Sheath,
which is actually just insulation.
It helps to firing work quicker.
So here are some facts about neurons.
There are a lot of them,
about a thousand billion of them,
and each neuron can be connected to around thousands,
perhaps tens of thousands of other neurons.
So it's an extraordinarily complicated computing device.
Neurons come in three flavors.
There are sensory neurons,
which takes information from the world.
So as you see me,
for instance,
um,
there are neurons firing from your retina,
sending signals to your brain.
There are motor neurons.
If you decide to raise your hand.
Those are motor neurons telling the muscles what to do.
And there are interneurons which connect the two and basically the inter neurons
do the thinking.
They make the connection between sensation in action.
Um,
it used to be believed and it's the sort of thing I would've when I taught this
course many years ago,
I would lecture on that.
Neurons do not grow back.
Once you lose them,
um,
they,
you never get them back.
This is actually not true.
There are parts of the brain in which neurons can regrow.
One interesting thing about neurons is a neuron is like a gun.
It either fires or it doesn't,
it's all or nothing.
Um,
if you squeeze the trigger of a gun really hard and really fast,
it doesn't fire any faster or harder than if you just squeezed it gently.
Um,
that is seems to be strange.
Wha How could neurons be all or nothing when sensation is very graded?
If somebody next to you pushed on your hand,
um,
the degree of pushing,
you'd be able to notice it.
It's not either pushing or not pushing.
You can degrees of pushing the Greens of heat,
degrees of brightness.
And the answer is although neurons are all or nothing,
there are ways to code intensity.
So one simple way to code intensity is the number of neurons firing the more
neurons and more intent.
Another way to increase intensity is the frequency of firing.
Um,
so
I'll just use those two.
The first one is the number of neurons firing.
The second one is the frequency of firing in that something is more intense.
If it's bang,
Bang,
Bang.
And these are two ways through which neurons,
Incode intensity.
Now neurons are connected and they talk to one another
and it used to be thought they were tied to one another.
Like a computer.
Like you take wires and you connect wires to each other,
you wrap them around and connect them.
Um,
it turns out this isn't the case.
It turns out that neurons relate to one another chemically in a kind of
interesting way between any neurons between the Axon of one neuron and the
dendrite of another.
It was a tiny gap.
The gap could be about one 10000th of a millimeter wide.
This infant decimal gap and this gap is known as a synapse.
And what happens is when a neuron fires an axon sense chemicals shooting through
the gap,
these chemicals are known as neuro transmitters and they affect the den rights.
So neurons communicate to one another chemically.
Um,
these again,
the chemicals could excite the other neuron,
excitatory,
bring up the chances that we'll fire or inhibit the other neuron inhibitory.
Now Neuro transmitters become interesting because alon of psychopharmacology,
um,
both of the medical sort end,
a recreational sort consists of fiddling with transmitters.
And so you could,
you could see this through some examples.
Um,
there are two sorts of ways you could fiddle with neurotransmitters and
correspondingly,
two sorts of drugs that are agonists.
And what an agonist does is increases the effect of neuro transmitters either by
making more neuro transmitters or stopping the cleanup of neurotransmitters or
in some cases by faking a neuro transmitter by mimicking his effects.
Then there are antagonists that slow down the amount of neurotransmitter's
either because they destroyed neuro transmitters or they make it hard to create
more.
Or in some cases,
they go to the den,
right of the neuron and it kind of put a paste over it so that the
neurotransmitters can't connect.
And it's through these clever ways that neurons can affect your mental life.
Okay?
So for instance,
mmm,
there is a drug known as Carrari and Carrari,
um,
is an antagonist.
It's a very particular sort of antagonist.
It,
um,
it blocks motor neurons from effecting muscle fibers.
What this does then is it paralyzes you because your motor neurons,
you send the command to your arm to stand,
to lift up.
It doesn't work.
You send a command your leg just to move.
The Motor neurons are rd activated.
Um,
and then because the way you breathe is through motor neurons,
you didn't die.
There's alcohol.
Alcohol is inhibitory.
Now,
this may be puzzling to people.
It's,
it's mildly paradoxical because you may be thinking alcohol is not inhibitory.
On the contrary,
when I drink a lot of alcohol,
I lose my inhibitions and become a more fun person.
I become,
I become more aggressive and more sexually vibrant and simply more beautiful.
And,
and so in what ways alcohol?
Inhibitory.
Well,
the answer is it,
it,
it inhibits the inhibitory parts of your brain.
So you have parts of your brain that are basically telling you now largely in
the frontal lobes,
okay,
keep your pants on.
Don't hit anybody,
don't use bad words.
Alcohol relaxes,
shuts down those parts of the brain.
If you take enough alcohol,
it then goes down to inhibit the excitatory parts of your brain and then you
fall on the floor and pass out
amphetamines.
Increased amount of arousal in particular,
they increased amount of norepinephrine.
I'm a neurotransmitter's as responsible for,
um,
just general arousal.
And so I'm Pheta means include drugs like speed and coke.
Um,
there are,
ah,
PROZAC works on Serotonin when we discuss clinical psychology and depression.
Um,
we'll learn the extent to which neurotransmitter disorders are implicated in
certain disorders like depression.
And one problem is that,
um,
for depression is that there's too little of a neurotransmitter known as
Serotonin.
Um,
Prozac make serotonin more prevalent and so in some extent might help alleviate
depression.
Um,
Parkinson's disease is a disease involving destruction of motor control and loss
of motor control,
difficulty moving.
Um,
and one factor in Parkinson's is too little of a neurotransmitter known as
dopamine.
The drug,
L-dopa increases the supply of dopamine and so does something to alleviate at
least temporarily the symptoms of Parkinson's.
So you have neurons and their cluster together and they fire and the communicate
to one another.
So how does this all work to give rise to creatures who could do interesting
things like talk and think?
Well,
again,
it used to be believed that the brain is wired up like a computer,
like a PC or a mac or something like that.
But we know this can't be true.
It can't be true because there's two ways in which the brain is better than a
computer.
For one thing,
the brain is highly resistant to damage.
If you have a laptop and I persuade you to open it up for me and I take the
pliers and kind of snip just about anywhere your laptop will be destroyed,
but the brain is actually more resilient.
You can take a lot of brain damage and still preserve some mental functioning to
some interesting sands through some sort of damage resistance built into the
brain that allows different parts of the brain to take over if some parts are
damaged.
A second consideration is the brain is extremely fast.
Your computer works on wires and electricity,
but your brain uses tissue and tissue is extremely slow.
The paradox then is how do you create such a fast computer with such slow stuff
and you can't,
what if,
if the,
if the brain was wired up like a personal computer,
it would take you four hours to recognize a face,
but in fact we could do things extremely quickly.
So the question then is how is the brain wired up?
And the answer is unlike many come on like commercially generated computers,
the brain works through parallel processing,
massively parallel distributed processing.
There's a whole lot of research and this is research,
some of which takes place outside psychology departments and an engineering
departments and computer science departments trying to figure out how a computer
can do the same things brains can do.
And one way people do this is they take a hint from nature and they try to
construct massively distributed networks to do aspects of reasoning.
So there's a very simple computational network that is interesting because it
kind of looks to some extent like the way neurons look.
And this is often known as neural networks and people who study this often claim
to be studying neural network modeling to try to build smart machines by
modeling them after brains.
And in the last 20 years or so,
this has been a huge and vibrant area of study where people are trying to wire
up machines that can do brain-like things from components that look a lot like
neurons and are wired up together as neurons are.
Um,
one consideration and all of this is that this is a very young field and nobody
knows how to do it yet.
There is no machine yet that can recognize faces or understand sentences at the
level of a two year old human.
There is no machine yet that can do just about anything people can do in an
interesting way.
And this is in part because the human brain is wired up and an extraordinarily
more complicated way then any sort of simple neural network.
This is the sort of schematic diagram.
You're not responsible for this,
um,
of,
of parts of the visual cortex.
And the thing to realize about this is it's extraordinarily simplified.
So the brain is a complicated system.
Now,
so we've talked a little bit about the basic building blocks of the brain
neurons.
Um,
we then talked about how neurons can communicate to one another,
then turned to how neurons are,
um,
are wired up together.
Now let's talk a little bit about different parts of the brain.
Now there's some things you don't actually need your brain to do.
The study of what you don't need your brain to do has often drawn upon this
weird,
um,
methodology where this was actually done in France a lot where they would
decapitate people.
And when after the capitated people,
psychologists would rush to the body of the headless person and sort of chess,
Tessa reflexes and stuff like that.
It's kind of gruesome,
but we know there are some things you don't need your brain for.
You don't need your brain for newborn sucking.
Um,
limb flex,
Asian in withdrawal from pain.
Your limb will pull back even if your head is gone.
Erection of the penis can be done with voter brain vomiting.
Also done with voter braid hair.
I need,
I need a volunteer.
Um,
very simple.
This will not involve any of the excellent,
any of the above.
Could you stand up just,
okay,
this is a new shirts.
I want to stay away because no,
this is if you hold out your hand and one hand flat.
Excellent.
That's the textbook fifth edition.
Um,
now perfect.
What you'll notice is thank you very much.
Well,
you're notices this hit and his hand went back up.
This is something automatic,
instinctive and there's not require your brain so your brain isn't needed for
everything.
What does your brain do?
Well,
some things that your brain does involve very low level internal structures.
Um,
and these are called subcortical structures because they're below the cortex
there underneath the cortex.
So for instance,
what we have here is a diagram of the brain.
The way to read this diagram is it's as if it were my brain,
I'm facing this way.
My head gets cut in half down here and then you could see the brain.
So this is the front of her hair.
That's the back.
Um,
some key parts are illustrated here.
The Medulla for instance,
is I'm responsible for heart rate and respiration.
It's very deep within the brain and if it gets damaged,
you could,
you're likely to die.
The cerebellum is responsible for body balance and muscular coordination.
And to give you again,
a feeling for the complexity of these systems.
The cerebellum contains approximately 30 billion neurons in the hypothalamus is
responsible here for feeding hunger,
thirst,
and to some extent sleep.
And here's the same brain parts in closeup.
Now
all of these parts of the brains are essential and many of them are implicating
the interesting psychological processes.
But where the action is is the Cortex isn't this beautiful.
Um,
the Cortex is the outer layer and the elder layer is all crumpled up.
You ever wonder why your brain looks wrinkled?
Um,
that's because it's all crumbled.
if you took out somebody cortex and flattened it out,
it would be about two feet square,
sort of like a nice Elica rug.
Um,
and the Cortex is where all the neat stuff takes place.
fish don't have any of it,
so no offense to fish,
but I think that's fish don't have much of a mental life.
Reptiles and birds have a little bit about it.
I've it and primates have a lot and humans have a real lot.
80% of the volume of our brain,
a belt is cortex and the cortex can be broken up into different parts or lobes.
There is the,
and again,
this is facing in profile forward.
There is the frontal lobe,
easy to remember it as parked in front
the parietal lobe,
the occipital lobe and the temporal lobe.
Okay.
One theme we're going to return to is this is half the brain.
It's,
this is in fact the left half of the brain and the other half,
the right half.
Everything's duplicated with some slight and subtle differences.
What's really weird,
one really weird finding about these lobes is that include topological maps.
They include maps of your body.
Um,
here's a cartoon which actually illustrates a classic experiment by some
physiologists who for some reason had had a dog's brain opened up and started
shocking different parts of the brain.
You could do brain surgery while fully conscious cause the brain itself has no
sense organs to it and it turns out that the dog,
when is that part of his brain,
his leg would kick up and uh,
took Dr Pennfield.
I'm at Mcgill University to do the same thing with people.
So they are doing some brain surgery.
We had a little electrical thing just on,
I don't know how he got to do this.
These are the zapping it and boom,
the person parts of her body would move more than that.
When he zapped other parts of the brain,
people would claim to see colors and exact other parts of the brain.
People would claim to hear sounds and other parts of the brain people would
claim to experience touch.
And through his research and other research it was founded or a mass in the
brain of the body.
There is a map in the motor part of the brain,
the motor Cortex,
uh,
of the sword up on the left and the sensory cortex of the sort that you could
see on the right.
And if you and you could tell what's what,
by opening up the brain and shocking different parts and those parts will
correspond to the parts of the body,
um,
shown in the diagram there.
Now two things to notice about these maps.
Um,
the first is their top topographical.
And what this means is that if two parts of the two parts are close together on
the Bondi,
there'll be close together on the brain.
So your um,
your tongue is closer to your jaw,
then it is to your hip in the body.
So too in both the motor cortex and the somatosensory cortex.
Also,
you'll notice that the size of the body part represented in the brain does not
correspond to the size of the body part in the real world.
Rather what determines the size and the brain is the,
the f is the extent to which either they have motor command over it or sensory
control.
So there's a whole lot of sensory organs,
for instance,
focused along your tongue.
And that's why that's so big and an enormous amount on your face.
But your,
um,
your,
your shoulder is that even Disney mean make it on there because I'll know your
shoulder might be bigger than your tongue.
There's not much going on.
In fact,
if you draw a diagram of a person,
what their body is corresponding to the amount of Somata sensory cortex,
you get something like that.
That's your sensory body.
Um,
now,
so you have these maps in your head,
but the thing to realize is,
and these maps are part of your cortex,
but the things to realize is that's an important part of what goes on in your
brain.
But less than one quarter of the cortex contains these maps or projection areas.
The rest is involved in language and reasoning and moral thought and so on.
And in fact,
the proportion as you go from rat,
cat monkey,
humans,
less and less of it is devoted to projection areas and more and more to other
things.
So how do we figure out what the other parts of the brain do?
Well,
there's all sorts of methods.
Typically these are reason imaging methods like cat scan and pet scan and FM ri.
Um,
which as I said before,
show parts of your brain at work.
If you want to know which part of your brain is responsible for language,
you could put somebody into a scanner and have them exposed to language or doing
linguistic tasks or talk or something,
and then see what parts of their brain are active.
Um,
another way to explore what the brain does is to consider what happens to people
when very bad things happen to their brain.
Um,
and these bad things could happen through lesions,
through tumors,
through strokes,
uh,
through injury.
Um,
for the most part,
neuro psychologists don't like helmet laws.
Um,
neuropsychologists love when motorcyclists drive about helmets because through
their horrible accidents,
we gained great insights into how the brain works.
And the logic is if you find somebody crudely behind somebody with damaged to
this part of the brain right here,
and that person can recognize faces,
for instance,
there some reason to believe that this part of the brain is related to face
recognition.
Um,
and so through the study of brain damage and the study,
if we can gain some understanding of what different parts of the brain do and
some people study brain damages,
brain damage,
that implicates motor control such as a praxia.
And what's interesting about a Praxia is it's not paralysis.
Somebody with a Praxia can move,
do simple movements just fine,
but they can't coordinate their movements.
They can't do something like wave goodbye or light a cigarette.
There's Agnosia and Magnolia is a disorder which isn't blindness because the
person who could still see perfectly well,
their eyes are intact.
But rather what happens in Agnosia is they lose the ability to recognize certain
things.
Sometimes this is described as psychic blindness and so they may get visual
Agnosia.
And lose the ability to recognize objects.
They may get prosopagnosia and lose the ability to recognize faces.
There are,
there are disorders of sensory neglect.
Um,
some famous disorders,
again,
it's not paralysis is not blindness,
but due to certain parts of your damaged parts of your brain,
you might lose.
For instance,
the idea that there's a left side of your body or left side of the world.
And these cases are so interesting.
I want to devote some chunk to a class in the next few weeks to discussing them.
There are disorders of language like Aphasia.
Um,
the classic case was discovered by Paul Broca in 1861.
A patient who had damaged to part of his brain and can only say one word,
Tan
and a pretty day 10,
10,
10 and everything else was gone.
Um,
there's other disorders of language such as receptive aphasia where the person
who could speak very fluently but the words don't make any sense and they can't
understand anybody else.
Other disorders that we'll discuss later on include acquired psychopathy were
damaged to parts of your brain,
particularly related to the frontal lobes.
Rob,
you have the ability to tell right from wrong.
The final I want to end,
we're talking about neurons,
connections,
me,
neurons,
how neurons are wired up,
the parts of the brain,
what the different parts do I want to end by talking about the two halves of the
brain
and ask the question,
how many minds do you have?
Now,
if you look at the brain,
if you took the brain out and held it up,
it would look pretty symmetrical,
but it actually is not.
There were actual differences between the right hemisphere and the left
hemisphere.
How many people here are right handed?
How many people here are left handed?
How many people here?
I've heard a complicated ambidextrous.
Don't know bitter.
The right middle left
people,
okay.
Those of you who are right handed,
um,
which comprises about nine out of 10 people have language in your left
hemisphere.
And in fact,
we're going to be talking about right handed people for the most part,
making generalizations in what I'll talk about.
Now those of you who are left handed are more complicated.
Um,
some of you have language in your right hemisphere.
Summon your left hemisphere.
Some God knows where it's complicated.
Um,
now the idea is that some things are duplicated.
So if you were to lose half of your brain,
the other half can actually do a lot.
But some things are more prevalent and more powerful in one part of the brain
than the other.
And I want to show you a brief film clip from scientific American that
illustrates the difference is between the hemispheres.
But before doing that,
I want to provide some introductory facts.
Um,
some functions or lateralized.
So typically language in the left,
again,
this is a right handed centric thing,
but if you're right handed language and left math and music on there,
right,
there is a crossover.
And this is important when we think about the studies that will follow.
But the crossover is that everything you see in the left visual field goes to
the right side of your brain.
Everything in the right visual field goes to the left side of the brain.
And similarly there's a crossover,
an action.
So your right hemisphere controls the left side of the body.
Your left hemisphere controls the right side of her body.
Now finally,
the two halves are connected.
They're connected by this huge web called the Corpus callosum.
Okay.
And I'm just going to skip this because the movie illustration,
we'll go through some of this.
This illustrates certain themes that are discussed in,
in the grade book concerning lateralization of different parts of different
mental capacities,
some of the left hemisphere seminar,
right hemisphere.
But it also serves as a useful method,
logical,
um,
development,
which is a nice illustration as to how looking at people who are incredibly
unusual,
such as this man who had his brain by sector.
So there's left hemisphere and right hemisphere,
don't communicate one another.
How looking at such people,
such extreme cases can provide us with some understanding of,
of how we normally do things.
And this again is a theme we'll return to throughout the course.
Um,
this is generally the general introduction of the brain that I want it to
provide.
Giving the framework for what I'll be talking about later on throughout the
course so that I might later on make reference to neurons or neuro transmitters
or the cortex or the left hemisphere.
And you'll sort of have the background to understand what I'm talking about.
But I want to end this first real class with,
uh,
a bit of humility
as to what psychologists know and don't know.
So the idea behind a lot of psychology,
particularly a lot of neuroscience and cognitive psychology is the treat the
mind is an information processor as an elaborate computer.
Um,
and so we study different problems like recognizing faces or language or motor
control or logic.
The strategy then often is to figure out how,
what sort of program can solve these problems.
And then we go on to ask,
how could this program be instantiated in a physical brain?
So we would have saw,
we study people much as we'd study a computer from an alien planet or something.
And I think people I,
this strategy is one I'm very enthusiastic about,
but there's still remains what's sometimes called the hard problem of
consciousness.
And this involves subjective experience.
What's it like?
So my computer can play chess,
my computer can recognize numbers,
it can do math and maybe it does it kind of the same way that I do it,
but my computer doesn't have feelings in the same sense.
Um,
this is,
these are two classic illustrations and this is from a very old star trek
episode.
It illustrates angst I think is starships about to go into the sun or something.
Um,
and that's my older kid Max who's happy.
and so the question is how does a thing like that give rise to consciousness and
subjective experience?
And this is a deep puzzle and although some psychologists and philosophers think
they've,
that most of us are a lot more skeptical,
most of us think we have so far to go before we can answer questions like
Huxley's question.
Um,
Huxley points out how it is that anything so remarkable is the state of
consciousness comes about as a result of irritating nervous tissue.
Is just as unaccountable as the appearance of the Daejeon of the genie.
When Aladdin rubs his lap.
It seems like magic that a fleshy lump of grey,
disgusting me can give rise to these feelings.
The second bit of humility while in the class on is I am presenting here and
I'll be presenting throughout this semester.
What are you can call a mechanistic conception of mental life.
I'm not going to be talking about how beautiful it is and how wonderful it is
and how mysterious it is.
Rather when are we trying to explain it?
We're going to be trying to explain fundamental aspects of ourselves including
questions like how do we make decisions?
Why do we love our children?
What happens when we fall in love and so on.
Now you might find this sort of project in the end to be repellent.
You might worry about how this,
well,
this meshes with humanist values.
For instance,
when we deal with one another and illegal in a moral setting,
we think in terms of freewill and responsibility,
if we're driving,
you cut me off.
You chose to do that.
You know,
it reflects badly on you.
If you save a life at risk to your own,
your your you deserve praise.
You did something wonderful.
It might be hard to match this with a conception in which all actions are a
result of neurochemical physical processes.
It might also be hard to mesh notions such as the report it intrinsic value of
people and finally it might be hard to match the mechanistic notion of the mind
with the idea that people have spiritual value faced with this tension.
There are three possibilities you might choose to reject a scientific conception
of the mind.
Many people do.
You may choose to embrace dualism,
reject the idea that the brain is responsible for mental life and reject the
promise of a scientific psychology.
Alternatively,
you might choose to embrace the scientific worldview and reject all these
humanist values and there are some philosophers and psychologists who do just
that who claimed that freewill and responsibility and spiritual value and
intrinsic value are all illusions.
They're pre pre-scientific notions that get washed away in modern science or you
could try to reconcile them.
You could try to figure it out.
How to Mesh your scientific view of the mind with these humanist values you
might want to preserve,
and this is an issue which is going to return to throughout the course.
Okay.
I'll see you on Wednesday.